across a vast country grief devastation
loss Iranian Canadians have settled
widely and built lives here it's no
exaggeration everyone in the community
knows someone connected to the tragedy
Amon Carter Pune just 36 was a real
estate agent in a largely Iranian
Canadian area near Toronto he and his
wife were returning from visiting her
family in Tehran very positive attitude
very upbeat young aggressive very busy
he had it all and the wife he wanted the
job he wanted the life that he chose
that he wanted it could have been
something great Iman's wife pari nas
worked in a bank and was a relentless
fundraiser for a top Iranian Canadian
cultural festival the organization
doesn't know what it will do without her
they realized she's no longer with us so
it's a it's a big gap that we have to
fill in our committee and in our charity
nearly 30 victims of the tragedy came
from the western city of Edmonton a
small Iranian Canadian community there
has been gathering for vigils to
remember the dead among them two married
professors from the University of
Alberta and their young daughters this
Iranian Canadian Member of Parliament
has been meeting his constituents almost
constantly since news of the crash
emerged on Wednesday there are times
like this that we are really not a
hyphenated Canadian and we're just a
Canadian and as promised her always said
a Canadian is a Canadian is a Canadian
so although it has hit our community
everyone in the community knows someone
that knows someone with its impact on
diverse communities from Iranian
Canadians to academics the business
world and professions this tragedy is
going to continue to resonate even
beginning the healing process will take
a long time
Daniel Lac al Jazeera Toronto